I found that really understanding what
the interpreter is doing when it
executes my code and understanding
variable scope and closures really helps
me in writing concise applications that
other developers can easily read through
and understand how can our students use
these features to their advantage in
writing their own code well it should
become much clearer when we get to later
lessons where we start writing functions
that return objects with methods on them
meaning functions that are stored as
properties of the object but more
generally any time you see a function
with an input parameter that's quite
static meaning you don't expect the
parameter to take on a new value every
time you call the function that's an
opportunity to refactor your code such
that you store the value in a variable
from an outer scope because of the way
closures work the inner function will
always have access to the outer scope
variable even after the outer function
returns like I said we're going to see
plenty of examples of this in the
upcoming lessons